who keeps the best secret from you three
who has the best poker face
no it's pin elope yes I'm wildly yeah
nella P is really good
Willem Dafoe's really good yeah I even
Penelope and that thing before why no
because I got the trouble
vanellope fancy keep looking at me and
Shane do your impression calories do it
and then I do it and then she says I
heard what you did
I heard you voluntarily did impression
you don't get my permission
dude I thought you were gonna say you
know you keep the secrets of battles or
secret keeper oh no well that's true
that's the only thing so it's the only
secret everything else give me a of
something that's no I did really worry
out I got my wisdom teeth out I love the
way show Kate Hut's in the video to the
trailer I saw that is social media
that's pretty impressive so I have to
tell you I'm a huge fan of frozen thank
you I love all what's that huge fat to
small little you have a Christmas album
coming out yes you know how to sing mmm
lose yourself which is my favorite song
in the world to work out with my god
thankfully an Olaf so I'm bad from
singing the song let it go and work so I
thought we could sing together
what do you think I've even had the
verse here printed oh you don't say he's
actually on Broadway and he's won a Tony
but you see recommend a beautiful voice
okay let's just sing it yes okay wait
are we actually doing this are gonna be
interrupted by a that is going so viral
you know what I'm telling you know I was
impressed I'll tell you what's going
viral it's just cold you know when
you're so tired you're either freezing
or boiling yes I'm at that end
yeah she said the only thing that's
going viral and she's drinking orange
juice and taking vitamins and it's not
helping you weren't able to travel with
one of you guys just one person made you
want to travel with in this room well I
guess the whole cause in the whole cast
Dame Dame Judi Dench do you know I'm
gonna have to pick an L up because we
were bunk buddies in the film and I'm
you know she's a wonderful human being
yeah I've done some traveling with with
Josh while we were shooting movie yet I
did some traveling with Josh and and the
first time we went to Dublin to like
having all night you know again you know
extravaganza and I I had to take an
advil and go to
like midnight oh I wish he was kidding
that's that was that can we go around
darling and he goes I'm I need to stop
now I just need some good time cause
like we're in Dublin he goes I I know
but I've had enough time but it what I
do it again you do it Josh again yes
thank you as well I changed my answer
then
[Laughter]